all right big story over the weekend if
you were following as a PFT it just felt
like one domino after another was
falling it started on Friday with the
stunning announcement by the Washington
franchise that they will undertake a
thorough review of their name which
quickly became obvious the name will
change possibly by the start of the 2020
season and then came the Washington Post
interview of Ron Rivera the coach in
Washington who's made it clear he wants
to name the change he's got a couple of
names that he likes he's working with
owner Daniel Snyder Snyder out of a
country keeping a very tight nucleus of
advisors none of whom worked for the
team it feels like he's alienated from
the process but at this point with FedEx
speaking out with Nike speaking out with
Nike taking all Austin gear off of its
website and now with other companies
like Dick's and Target and Walmart not
selling any current Washington gear now
I thought there would be a run on the
stuff containing the name that's about
to go away all the fans of the team that
like that name they want to go snatch
that gear up because they want to have
it they want to wear it they want to
continue to represent the team with the
name that's going away it may be harder
and harder to find anybody that has some
you may want to check it back because
there may be some jerseys and hats and
jackets and stuff bearing that name that
is selling for a pretty penny now and
into the future
once that name changes and I think the
closer the name is to something that
honors as Ron marrow wants to do Native
Americans the more relevant the outdated
name will be that's why you can make the
argument a complete break from anything
having any relevance to Native Americans
to make that name even more meaningless
make that deer even more meaningless if
you have done a hard turn in a 180 and
it's something that has nothing to do
with Native Americans and as I've been
saying and writing at pft I think the
National Congress of American Indians
and other representative groups need to
have a seat at the table they need to be
consulted as to whether or not they even
want to
to be associated with that franchise
it's possible their attitude is screw
you guys
frankly we've been trying to get you to
do the right thing for years and now
only after you get significant economic
pressure from a couple years Fon sirs
do you decide to move forward FedEx was
founded by Fred Smith he is one of the
minority owners of the Washington
franchise Robert Rothman Dwight Schar
are the others Sunday's news and we
broke this as it relates to Smith and
char they have been trying to sell their
interest and this isn't something new
the way that the Post report of it was
char and Smith and they added Rothman to
the mix it creates the impression that
it's something recent that it's
something new
my understanding is they've been trying
for a while unsuccessfully to sell their
interest in the team and the reason
they're struggling you don't any say you
own a piece of the team but you've got
no power
you've got to defer to Daniel Snyder on
everything and you know really rich
people don't like to be in a position
like that so the people who may be in a
position to buy a chunk of the team at a
valuation of 3 billion dollars which
means if you've got 5% when my maths is
gonna fall apart here quickly what does
that work out to 1% of 3 billion would
be 30 million right so 5% would be 150
million do you want to write that kind
of a check for something that you would
have no say over no power over and maybe
based on everything you've heard about
the Anderson Eider he's just not the
kind of guy you want to be doing
business with according to the proposed
that's why char and Smith and Rothman
want out they're done with Daniel Snyder
and it creates an interesting dynamic
because I wouldn't be shocked if as the
indignity settles in for Daniel Snyder
the billionaire who's used to always
getting his way having to change his
name of the team after he came out and
said in 2013 he will never put that in
all caps never change the name he may
just decide I'm gonna cash out sell it
to Jeff Bezos sell it sell the 60% he
owns and maybe the other 40% that the
minority owners hold just sell it all to
be zoast and let him take the thing over
and I don't think the league would be
said about the guy who runs Amazon being
one of their partners as they try to
figure out long-term streaming deals you
know it's one thing to do a deal with
Beezus when he's not one of the owners
to one of the teams it's a very
different dynamic when he's one of the
people who is actually at the table with
you as you're trying to figure out what
these contracts are going to be so let's
keep an eye on what happens with these
minority owners they may sell and get
out of it and someone else comes in as a
partner for Daniel Snyder or maybe
Snyder gets out and they stay or
everybody gets out and somebody comes in
and buys 100% of the franchise moving
forward
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports